- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La séance est
ouverte. L'ordre du jour appelle les
questions au gouvernement.
La première d'entre elles va être
posée par monsieur Jérémie
Patrier-Leitus.
- Jérémie Patrier-Leitus: Merci,
madame la présidente.
Ma question s'adresse à madame la
Première ministre.
Madame la Première ministre,
dimanche dernier, des centaines de
Français au visage hagard et
sidéré, aux yeux embués et émus
ont marché en silence dans les
rues d'une ville dans le Calvados,
dont vous êtes l'élue.
Nous avons marché en silence pour
rendre hommage à une femme
lumineuse et rayonnante, une maman
de 28 ans, bibliothécaire
passionnée par son métier.
Elle aimait la vie.
Elle lui a été arrachée par son
compagnon qui, selon toute
vraisemblance, l'a assassinée à
l'arme blanche le 14 février
dernier.
Il y a un an, cette femme avait
brisé le silence et porté plainte
contre son compagnon pour
violences conjugales.
Cela n'aura pas suffi.
Elle reste le visage de toutes ces
femmes tombées sous les coups de
leur conjoint ou ex-conjoint.
Les chiffres sont glaçants.
28 femmes sont mortes assassinées
depuis janvier dernier.
Encore deux le week-end dernier.
Jour après jour, le décompte
macabre se poursuit et le même
bilan glaçant se répète.
Les familles sont brisées.
A ce chiffre épouvantable, nous
pouvons ajouter des centaines de
milliers de femmes victimes de
violences conjugales.
La République doit protéger
l'ensemble de ces filles et mettre
fin à ce fléau qui pourrit notre
société et traverse tous les
milieux sociaux.
Depuis plusieurs années, des
mesures ont été prises, mais force
est de constater que des failles
et des dysfonctionnements majeurs
persistent.
Madame la Première ministre, je
connais votre engagement et votre
détermination à lutter contre les
féminicides.
Il y a urgence à agir.
Nous le devons à toutes ces femmes
assassinées.
Ma question est simple: le plan
national d'urgence, pouvez-vous
mettre en place pour enrayer ce
fléau et dire aux femmes qui nous
écoutent en cette veille de la
Journée internationale pour le
droit des femmes que dans notre
pays, la République les protégera
toujours des coups de leur
conjoint, de la folie de leurs
prédateurs?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Isabelle Rome.
- Isabelle Rome: Merci.
Vous m'interpellez sur le drame
qui s'est produit le 14 février
dernier.
J'ai une pensée pour la victime.
Pour la deuxième fois, le
président de la République a fait
de l'égalité femmes-hommes, la
grande cause du quinquennat.
Ce combat contre les violences
intrafamiliales est un combat de
chaque instant sans relâche.
Tant qu'il
y aura des coups et des
féminicides, notre combat ne
s'arrêtera pas.
Demain, je vais présenter un plan
égalité 2027 qui comportera un
certain nombre de mesures
ambitieuses pour la protection de
ces femmes.
La Première ministre en a annoncé
hier quelques-unes, dont, par
exemple, l'ordonnance de
protection immédiate qui va
permettre une mise en sécurité
très rapide de la victime.
De même, pour aider les victimes à
s'extraire des griffes de leurs
bourreaux, car ce n'est pas facile
de quitter son conjoint quand il
est violent, la Première ministre
a annoncé la mise en place d'un
nouveau dispositif que j'ai pu
lancer la semaine dernière dans le
Val-d'Oise pour un premier
territoire d'expérimentation.
Ce dispositif va permettre aux
victimes de bénéficier d'aides,
avec un seul référent.
Que ce soit un accompagnement
psychologique, une aide à la garde
d'enfants, que ce soit aussi un
hébergement d'urgence ou des
soins.
Cela peut s'adresser aux femmes
qui quittent le domicile ou dont
le conjoint est évincé.
Nous devons rester humbles dans ce
combat et ne jamais faire de
triomphalisme.
Nous devons oeuvrer au quotidien
pour les femmes.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Aurélien Taché.
- Aurélien Taché: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Madame la ministre des Affaires
étrangères, le président de la
République est rentré dimanche à
Paris après une tournée de quatre
jours en Afrique centrale.
C'est l'heure du bilan.
Au Gabon, sous prétexte d'un
sommet sur la forêt, boycotté par
les ONG, le président n'a fait que
renforcer Ali Bongo.
Il s'affiche tout sourire avec le
président militaire et responsable
d'une guerre civile ayant entraîné
le massacre de milliers
d'opposants.
Il passera aussi en Angola, sans
dire un mot de l'immonde projet de
Total, qui a conduit à
l'expropriation de milliers de
paysans.
Il s'est rendu samedi en RDC, et
ce fut le clou du spectacle.
Incapable de dénoncer le
financement de la milice M23 par
le Rwanda, le président a insulté
son homologue.
Finalement, madame la ministre,
cette tournée d'Emmanuel Macron,
c'est un mélange de "Tintin au
Congo" et
d'"OSS 117 en Afrique".
Le sentiment antifrançais ne cesse
de croître.
Après notre échec en Libye et au
Sahel, des pays africains nous
demandent de fermer nos casernes
militaires.
Croyez-vous que ces Etats sont
aveugles à la différence de
traitement des réfugiés venus
d'Ukraine?
Nous sommes indifférents aux
conflits qui frappent leur
continent.
Emmanuel Macron a reçu un
responsable de massacres, le mois
dernier.
Il faut arrêter avec le double
standard de droits humains et de
démocratie en Afrique.
C'est avec les diasporas, la
société civile et la jeunesse que
de nouvelles coopérations doivent
se construire à égalité.
Madame la ministre, vous qui êtes
une diplomate aguerrie, ma
question est simple: qu'avez-vous
pensé de cette tournée d'Emmanuel
Macron en Afrique?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Catherine Colonna.
- Catherine Colonna: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Monsieur le député, ce 25 février,
le président de la République a
posé notre cap envers l'Afrique.
C'est un continent qui présente
beaucoup de potentialités pour les
prochaines décennies.
Nous voulons créer des
partenariats équilibrés, dans le
respect réciproque.
Sans arrogance, mais sans
complexes.
Sans arrogance, parce que nous
n'avons ni besoin de donner notre
vision du monde.
Nous avons des atouts à faire
valoir.
Engagement de notre jeunesse, nos
entreprises, nos universités.
Sans complexes, parce que nous
avons une proximité à entretenir,
sans connivence ni ingérence et en
ne soutenant aucun candidat.
Nous devons parler avec tout le
monde, y compris avec les
oppositions, comme toujours.
Nous avons une présence économique
à encourager dans un esprit
gagnant-gagnant.
Nous avons de nouveaux
partenariats à bâtir.
Sans relâche, nous devons
continuer de lutter contre les
fractures et contre les
incompréhensions, la réponse ne
saurait donc être dans la prise de
distance, mais au contraire dans
l'approfondissement du dialogue.
Je vous invite à y participer,
monsieur le député.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Manuel Bompard.
- Manuel Bompard: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Madame la Première ministre, ce
mardi 7 mars fera date dans
l'histoire de France.
A l'heure où je vous parle,
plusieurs millions de personnes
défilent dans les rues.
Les plus petites communes
comme les grandes métropoles.
C'est tout le pays qui se lève.
Nous vivons la plus grande journée
de grève et de manifestations
depuis 50 ans.
A l'heure où je vous parle,
l'essentiel des trains, des métros
et des bus ne circulent plus.
Aucune goutte de carburant ne sort
des raffineries.
Les chaînes de l'industrie sont à
l'arrêt.
Les centrales électriques
réduisent leur production et,
d'ores et déjà, les assemblées
générales ont décidé de poursuivre
la grève pour demain.
Vous faites la sourde oreille.
Vous ignorez, vous méprisez, vous
mentez, vous misez sur le
découragement.
Vous tentez de dresser les
Français les uns contre les
autres.
Vous faites du mal à un pays qui
souffre déjà beaucoup, et vous
êtes irresponsable.
Chaque jour qui passe,
l'opposition à votre réforme
s'amplifie.
L'ensemble des syndicats ont
appelé au blocage du pays.
Deux tiers des Français les
soutiennent dans cette démarche.
Les caisses de grève se
remplissent.
Le peuple est solidaire de ceux
qui sacrifient des journées de
salaire pour défendre l'intérêt
général.
Nous leur apportons notre soutien
total.
Madame la Première ministre, vous
ne pouvez pas gouverner seule
contre tout le monde.
Il n'y a pas de 49.3 contre
l'union populaire.
Il n'y a pas de honte à reculer.
D'autres l'ont fait, avant vous.
En 1995, il aura fallu trois
semaines de grève pour l'abandon
du plan Juppé.
En 2006, un mois de manifestations
aura permis la fin du CPE.
Madame la Première ministre,
combien de temps allez-vous faire
payer au pays le prix de votre
entêtement?
Quand allez-vous enfin retirer
votre texte de loi?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Olivier Dussopt.
- Olivier Dussopt: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Mesdames et messieurs les députés,
monsieur le député Bompard, votre
question, par son ton comme par
son fond est symptomatique de
votre positionnement politique.
Vous appelez au blocage.
Pour reprendre l'expression d'un
responsable syndical, vous voulez
"mettre l'économie à genoux".
C'est mettre les travailleurs à
genoux, les classes modestes,
mettre en difficulté les petites
entreprises, les plus fragiles.
Votre question est symptomatique,
car, d'un mot, vous dites que nous
sommes seuls.
Elle n'est pas seule.
La Première ministre est
accompagnée par toute la majorité.
Elle est accompagnée, au-delà de
la majorité, par toutes celles et
ceux qui, en responsabilité,
savent que ce que nous faisons,
c'est de garantir la solidarité
intergénérationnelle.
Monsieur le député, votre question
est symptomatique pour une
troisième raison: quand vous
faites le choix de l'outrance, des
grandes déclarations et du
blocage, vous faites le choix de
l'obstruction.
Avons fait le choix du débat et de
la discussion.
Vous avez fait un choix qui est
finalement le choix d'esquiver.
Vous avez esquivé la
responsabilité.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Emilie Chandler.
- Emilie Chandler: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Ma question s'adresse à Eric
Dupond-Moretti.
Le 8 mars, Journée internationale
du droit des femmes.
19 novembre, autre Journée
internationale pour les enfants.
Il y a
des dates dans notre calendrier
qui sont une occasion de plus pour
appeler les violences qui sont
présentes dans les familles.
Ces violences, elles brisent des
familles et des vies.
Au-delà des chiffres que l'on
connaît, ce sont des gens qui
meurent.
Depuis le 28 septembre, avec la
sénatrice Dominique Vérien, nous
travaillons dans le cadre de la
mission qui nous a été confiée par
madame la Première ministre, qui
vise à améliorer le traitement
judiciaire des violences
intrafamiliales.
Nous avons rendu certaines
recommandations.
Ce que nous demandent les victimes
et les associations, ce que nous
demandent les Français,
c'est d'avancer avec un pack
nouveau départ.
Il y aura une mise en place d'une
ordonnance de protection.
Au cours de la mission, j'ai pu
constater que la circulaire de
privation de l'information entre
les différents acteurs de la
chaîne judiciaire est un élément
essentiel pour lutter contre la
violence au sein des familles.
Toutes les juridictions ont
développé ce modèle.
Il est important d'aider nos
concitoyens à mieux s'y retrouver.
Sur l'ordonnance de protection
immédiate que nous avions
proposée, l'annonce faite semble
entraîner beaucoup
d'interrogations.
Pourriez-vous apporter des
précisions sur les modalités de
ces deux mesures annoncées par
madame la Première ministre?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Eric
Dupond-Moretti.
- Eric Dupond-Moretti: Merci.
Madame la députée Emilie Chandler,
je sais à quel point, depuis le 28
septembre, vous êtes investies
pour améliorer encore la réponse
que nous pouvons apporter à ces
terrifiants féminicides.
Nous avons déjà, vous le savez,
beaucoup fait.
Bracelet anti-rapprochement,
ordonnance de protection,
déferrement ou condamnation
beaucoup plus ferme, mais force
est de constater que cela n'est
pas suffisant.
Hier, vous avez présenté un
certain nombre de propositions qui
ont été reprises avec enthousiasme
par madame la Première ministre,
et que je reprendrais à mon compte
avec le même enthousiasme.
Il s'agit de pôles spécialisés, et
non pas de juridictions.
Vous avez auditionné une centaine
de personnes.
Je veux rappeler que ces pôles ont
été mis en place.
Il faut généraliser ces pôles à
l'ensemble des tribunaux
judiciaires.
Ils sont 164.
La deuxième mesure, qui est
importante, c'est l'ordonnance de
protection.
Elle était prise dans un délai de
40 jours.
Nous l'avons réduite à six jours.
Il faut encore impérativement
réduire ce délai, à 24 heures,
comme l'a annoncé la dame la
Première ministre.
Nous allons trouver évidemment
toutes les solutions pour
présenter le plus rapidement
possible un texte qui va dans ce
sens pour une raison simple,
madame la députée, c'est que c'est
le bon sens.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Jean-Philippe
Tanguy.
- Jean-Philippe Tanguy:
Ma question s'adresse à madame la
Première ministre.
Une hausse des prix de
l'alimentation de 25% en seulement
18 mois.
Voilà la réalité que doivent
affronter les Français quand les
salaires, eux, n'ont augmenté que
de 4% à 6% sur la même période.
Entre mensonges grossiers et
incompétence crasse, vous avez
promis que l'inflation était sous
contrôle.
On voit le résultat!
Vous aviez promis des mesures
jamais vues, fortes.
On voit le résultat: un pauvre
logo, un
énième slogan pour faire la
publicité de la grande
distribution aux frais du
contribuable.
Vous aviez promis un carburant
proche de 1,50 euro.
Il est presque à deux euros.
Vous avez supplié TotalEnergies de
partager les 35 milliards de
bénéfices que vous avez sciemment
protégés.
En réalité, madame la Première
ministre, comment vous pourriez
combattre l'inflation dont vous
chérissez les causes?
La Banque centrale a rendu son
verdict.
Ce ne sont pas les hausses de
salaires qui nourrissent
l'inflation.
Elles sont faméliques.
Ce n'est pas l'emballement de
l'économie réelle, elle est au
bord de l'effondrement.
Ce qui nourrit aujourd'hui
l'inflation, c'est
les surprofits indécents que font
les multinationales.
Vous avez protégé ces surprofits.
Seule Marine Le Pen avait eu le
courage de le dire.
C'est le travail des Français qui
paye la cupidité des
multinationales.
Ma question est simple: quand
allez-vous rendre leur argent aux
Français?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
- Bruno Le Maire: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Monsieur le député Jean-Philippe
Tanguy, la justice fiscale, c'est
nous.
L'incompétence fiscale, c'est
vous.
La justice fiscale, c'est d'aller
taxer l'ensemble des énergéticiens
pour récupérer la rente qu'ils ont
faite sur l'électricité ou sur le
gaz, pour apporter 46 milliards
d'euros au Trésor public, que vous
n'avez pas voté.
La justice fiscale, c'est la mise
en place d'une imposition
minimale, une imposition sur le
revenu poussée par cette majorité,
ce gouvernement, défendue et
obtenue par le président de la
République.
15% de taxation minimale.
La justice sociale et fiscale,
c'est taxer les gens du numérique,
Google, Amazon et Facebook, ceux
qui n'étaient pas taxés jusqu'à
présent.
Ils vont être taxés pour 700
millions d'euros de revenu fiscal
en 2023.
Vous ne l'avez pas voté, mesdames
et messieurs du Rassemblement
National.
Vous ne défendez pas la justice
fiscale.
Vous n'avez qu'un seul mot la
bouche: la TVA, la TVA et la TVA.
Si nous baissions la TVA sur les
produits alimentaires, ça
coûterait 7 milliards d'euros.
Si vous la baissions sur
l'essence, ça coûterait 10
milliards d'euros.
A supposer que ça n'aille pas dans
la poche des distributeurs ou des
industriels, c'est toujours trois
fois moins que les 46 milliards
d'euros que nous avons mis pour
protéger les Français contre
l'augmentation des prix de
l'électricité et du gaz.
L'incompétence, c'est vous.
La décision de la justice, c'est
nous.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Jean-Philippe
Tanguy.
- Jean-Philippe Tanguy: Monsieur
le ministre, comment pourriez-vous
taxer les superprofits d'EDF,
puisque vous avez ruiné cette
entreprise, qui fait 18 milliards
de pertes?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Annie Genevard.
- Annie Genevard: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à madame la
Première ministre.
Nouvelle illustration du "en même
temps" cher au président de la
République: notre pays a réussi la
performance diplomatique d'être en
froid avec l'Algérie et avec le
Maroc.
Le Maroc a rappelé son ambassadeur
à Paris le 19 janvier dernier et a
dénoncé ces derniers jours des
relations avec la France qui sont
"ni bonnes, ni amicales".
C'est un terrible constat.
Le 8 février, c'était au tour de
l'Algérie de rappeler son
ambassadeur pour consultation afin
de protester contre l'expulsion
d'une militante.
Le pays a annoncé dans la foulée
qu'il cesserait de décerner les
laissez-passer consulaires.
L'Algérie ne reprend désormais
plus aucun de ses ressortissants
expulsés par la France.
Madame la Première ministre,
au-delà des conséquences
diplomatiques désastreuses qui
contribuent à affaiblir toujours
plus notre pays, déjà à la peine
sur le continent africain, cette
crise avec deux pays majeurs du
Maghreb révèle une fois de plus
l'échec de votre politique
d'expulsion des étrangers en
situation irrégulière.
0,2% avec l'Algérie et 2,4% avec
le Maroc.
Comment, madame la Première
ministre, dans ces conditions
diplomatiques particulièrement
défavorables, comptez-vous
réaliser la promesse de votre
ministre de l'Intérieur
d'atteindre 100% des OQTF?
Un engagement qui apparaît au
mieux comme un voeu pieux, au
pire comme une promesse à laquelle
on ne peut accorder le moindre
crédit.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Catherine Colonna.
- Catherine Colonna: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Madame la députée, la France est
liée au Maroc et à l'Algérie par
des liens d'une nature
exceptionnelle, des liens qui
dépassent les personnes et les
contingences.
Ils prennent racine dans une
histoire partagée, une histoire
d'une richesse, mais aussi d'une
complexité hors du commun.
Ces liens hors du commun, on peut
les voir à l'oeuvre dans les
échanges humains.
Nos trois pays sont liés,
indéfectiblement, par leur
jeunesse, leurs étudiants et leur
langue.
Par leur histoire aussi, les
histoires familiales, les
histoires imbriquées dans la
grande histoire.
Malheureusement, madame la
députée, dans ce genre de
relations on ne peut éviter des
périodes de doute et des accrocs.
Ce qui est important, c'est ce qui
est important pour l'avenir.
Il y a eu une visite d'amitié par
le présent de la République fin
août.
Il y a eu aussi celle de la
Première ministre en automne.
Ca trace les perspectives pour le
temps long entre nos deux pays, y
compris sur le plan mémoriel.
Il est de la responsabilité de
tous de contribuer à développer
notre relation avec l'Algérie.
Ce que nous voulons pour l'avenir,
madame la députée, c'est aussi ce
que j'ai présenté au Maroc, en
décembre, lors d'une visite qui a
posé un jalon important et qui
était nécessaire.
Avec le Maroc comme avec
l'Algérie, nous regardons vers
l'avenir.
Nous avons une ambition forte.
Nous entendons poursuivre ce
travail au bénéfice de nos
peuples, et en particulier au
bénéfice de nos jeunesses.
Je vous remercie.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Annie Genevard.
- Annie Genevard: Ce double
fiasco, madame la ministre,
diplomatique et migratoire,
ne vous est sans doute pas
directement imputable.
Les conséquences sont là.
Je regarde le ministre de
l'Intérieur.
Aujourd'hui, plus aucune OQTF ne
peut être satisfaite notamment
avec l'Algérie.
Comment allez-vous répondre à ce
problème majeur de notre pays?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Christophe
Naegelen.
- Christophe Naegelen: Merci,
madame la présidente.
Madame la Première ministre, alors
que certains parlent de mettre la
France à genoux, je voulais vous
interpeller sur les personnes qui
sont aux côtés de nos concitoyens,
peu importe les cris et les
pandémies.
Les infirmières et les infirmiers
libéraux n'ont pas bénéficié de la
prime Covid, ni de celle du Ségur
de la santé.
Ils sont des maillons essentiels
pour notre société, pour assurer
la continuité des soins, dans un
contexte où le gouvernement
affiche une politique ambitieuse
du bien-vieillir à domicile.
Ils sont en première ligne.
Ils exercent un métier pénible,
dont la pénibilité n'est pas prise
en compte pour la retraite.
La revalorisation financière de
leurs actes est inchangée depuis
plus de 10 ans.
La France connaît un contexte
inflationniste préjudiciable à
tous.
Leurs indemnités forfaitaires de
déplacement sont fixées à 2,50
euros.
C'est à la base plus que minime.
Ca devient insignifiant, au vu de
l'augmentation du prix de
l'essence, d'autant plus que son
montant est indécent.
Au 31 décembre 2022, la prime
exceptionnelle au déplacement pour
ces professionnels qui
bénéficiaient depuis avril 2022
d'une maigre revalorisation de
quatre centimes a été supprimée.
Cette indemnité est complétée par
une indemnité kilométrique de 0,50
euro par kilomètre.
Il y a un préjudice qui est crée
pour nos territoires ruraux.
Une infirmière se voit refuser son
remboursement avec pour seule
faute d'exercer dans une commune
de 50 kilomètres carrés.
Que va faire le gouvernement pour
que nous puissions assouplir ces
conditions qui ne prennent pas en
compte la réalité de tous les
territoires?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame la Première
ministre.
- Elisabeth Borne: Merci.
Monsieur le président Christophe
Naegelen, vous avez raison de le
dire, les infirmiers et les
infirmières libéraux sont
indispensables.
Dans la France rurale, dans les
petites communes, dans les villes
moyennes, dans les montagnes, ils
sont les visages accessibles du
soin.
En semaine comme le week-end, ils
parcourent des dizaines de
kilomètres par jour au contact des
Français et Françaises qui en ont
besoin.
Au nom du gouvernement, je veux
leur dire toute ma reconnaissance.
Avec le ministre de la Santé,
François Braun, nous sommes
mobilisés à leurs côtés.
Concernant l'indemnité
kilométrique, nous sommes bien
conscients des difficultés,
notamment en cette allure de prix
élevés des carburants.
Dès 2019, le mode de calcul des
indemnités kilométriques a été
révisé pour prendre en compte la
réalité des déplacements.
Il n'y a plus de règles uniques.
C'est à l'échelle de chaque
département que cela peut être
négocié.
Je veux que l'on veille à la bonne
prise en compte des réalités
locales.
On a revalorisé les indemnités
kilométriques pour les infirmières
et infirmiers libéraux.
Ceux-ci ont bénéficié des
différentes aides mises en place
par le gouvernement qui ont été
doublées par l'Assurance maladie.
S'agissant de la rémunération,
nous avons mis en place le bilan
de soins infirmiers qui a rénové
le mode de facturation des actes
infirmiers avec une rémunération
forfaitaire journalière adaptée
aux patients.
Depuis le 1er janvier 2022, cet
outil a été étendu à l'ensemble
des patients dépendants.
Ce bilan de soins infirmiers
connaît un succès important.
Nous allons doubler les
financements avec 217 millions
d'euros d'ici 2024.
Pour autant, je sais que les
interrogations et les doutes, des
difficultés également, persistent.
Nous travaillons avec les
soignants pour faire évoluer le
métier d'infirmière libérale.
Nous voulons adapter les
formations, les référentiels
d'activité et les compétences.
Une mission commune
des inspections du ministère de la
Santé et de l'enseignement
supérieur est en cours sur le
sujet.
Le gouvernement se mobilise pour
enrichir ce métier d'infirmières
et infirmiers libéraux.
Cette évolution du métier
d'infirmière et d'infirmier va de
pair avec le renforcement de son
attractivité qui est l'une des
conditions pour assurer une
meilleure offre de soins sur tout
notre territoire.
Je sais que cette préoccupation
est largement partagée sur ces
bancs, comme en témoigne
l'adoption à l'unanimité de la
proposition de loi portée par la
rapporteure générale Stéphanie
Rist ces dernières semaines.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Fabien
Lainé.
- Fabien Lainé: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Monsieur le ministre de
l'Agriculture, je souhaite vous
interpeller à propos de la
situation sanitaire au regard de
l'influence aviaire qui frappe nos
éleveurs et toute la filière
agricole.
Le gouvernement a toujours été aux
côtés des acteurs de la filière
palmipède, via des indemnisations
massives.
Je souhaite saluer cet effort
constant.
Au printemps 2017, le ministre de
l'Agriculture avait signé un pacte
de biosécurité avec une filière
palmipède, créant ainsi des
mesures pour réduire les risques
de diffusion et de transmission.
Dans le sud-ouest de la France, le
gouvernement a mis en place un
plan ayant pour but de créer un
vide sanitaire.
Ce plan a permis de limiter
considérablement le nombre de
foyers, permettant de relancer le
repeuplement des volailles.
Malgré les avancées conséquentes
de la biosécurité, la maladie se
répète et se généralise.
Fort heureusement, nous voyons un
espoir avec l'arrivée prochaine du
vaccin.
Sans que cela ne devienne un
substitut de la biosécurité, nous
devons envisager la vaccination
massive, qui ne peut se mettre en
place sans l'aide de l'Etat, qui
doit soutenir cette filière dans
cette démarche.
La vaccination doit se faire
volaille par volaille, avec un
coût unitaire du vaccin très
élevé.
En outre, on devra ajouter un
monitoring post-vaccination
particulièrement lourd et onéreux,
afin de garantir la crédibilité et
l'efficacité de la stratégie
vaccinale.
Compte tenu de ces conditions,
envisagez-vous la mise en place
d'un plan pour soutenir
financièrement nos éleveurs lors
du déploiement de la vaccination?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Marc Fesneau.
- Marc Fesneau: Monsieur le
député, merci de votre question
qui me permet de faire le point
sur l'influenza aviaire, et même
sur l'influenza toute seule.
Nous avons eu plus de 1400 foyers,
l'année dernière.
Je pense à tous les éleveurs
touchés, chez qui c'est le
deuxième ou le troisième épisode.
C'est quand même une meilleure
nouvelle que l'année dernière.
Nous avions des inquiétudes, l'an
dernier, parce que l'influenza
était endémique.
Nous avons été à la hauteur en
termes d'indemnisation des
éleveurs.
Plus d'un milliard d'euros ont été
prévus pour cette indemnisation en
2021 et 2022.
Nous avons mis en place le même
dispositif.
Que doit-on faire désormais?
La première chose, c'est le plan
dont vous avez parlé.
C'est un plan qui a été monté avec
les éleveurs, qui a été voulu par
les éleveurs.
Dans les périodes les plus à
risque, nous avons fait en sorte
qu'on ne repeuple pas tout de
suite les élevages pour éviter les
périodes où il y a plus de
contamination.
Il y avait 300 foyers dans la zone
sud-ouest, il n'y en a que 20
cette année.
Ca a donc marché.
L'objectif, c'est de prolonger ces
mesures.
On aura un accompagnement
financier.
Ensuite, il faudra penser la même
chose sur d'autres zones, regarder
comment on peut le faire, y
compris pour préserver le
patrimoine génétique qui sert pour
les canards qui est menacé par la
influenza en Pays de Loire du fait
des épisodes récents.
Troisième élément, la vaccination.
Nous avons les résultats qui vont
arriver au courant du mois de
mars.
On a déployé un plan.
Il faut faire de la logistique et
de la prévisibilité sur ces
sujets.
J'ai annoncé que le gouvernement
prendrait en charge une partie de
la vaccination.
On a besoin de travail sur les
normes de commerce.
Il y a des échanges internationaux
qui sont soumis à des règles de
vaccination.
Voilà les sujets sur lesquels nous
travaillons.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur Emeric
Salmon.
- Emeric Salmon: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Madame la Première ministre, mes
chers collègues, ma question
s'adresse à madame la Première
ministre.
Aujourd'hui, de très nombreux
Français sont dans la rue, comme
dans ma circonscription.
Ils vous signifient leur
opposition à votre réforme des
retraites dans le calme.
Les syndicats nous annoncent le
blocage de la France.
Ce blocage est une coproduction.
Vous en êtes la première
responsable.
C'est vous qui avez choisi de
faire passer votre néfaste,
inutile et injuste réforme des
retraites par un projet de loi de
finance rectificative de la
Sécurité sociale et ainsi limité
la durée du débat.
Ce débat, nous ne l'avons même pas
eu, à cause de l'obstruction de
l'extrême gauche NUPES, et c'est
vous, la responsable.
Je n'oublie pas que l'extrême
gauche NUPES, en avril dernier,
appelait à voter pour Emmanuel
Macron, dont le seul programme
était justement le recul de l'âge
de départ à la retraite.
Même récemment, ici, lorsqu'une
motion référendaire a été
discutée, l'extrême gauche NUPES,
parce qu'ils avaient perdu un pile
ou face, a préféré déserter.
Collègues de l'extrême gauche
NUPES, vous êtes coresponsables de
cette casse sociale.
Aujourd'hui, madame la Première
ministre, pour ne pas entraîner la
France dans un blocage qui
pourrait s'avérer dramatique pour
notre économie déjà bien malmenée
par votre politique, vous avez une
solution, vous pouvez sortir par
le haut: organiser un référendum.
Quand allez-vous proposer au
président de la République, comme
vous le permet l'article 11 de la
Constitution, de demander aux
Français de trancher par
référendum et si, oui ou non, ils
souhaitent l'application de votre
projet de loi?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Olivier Véran.
- Olivier Véran: Madame la
présidente, merci.
Monsieur le député Salmon,
d'abord, il n'y a pas lieu, encore
moins dans cet hémicycle,
d'envisager qu'il puisse y avoir
une sorte de conflit de légitimité
entre la légitimité de la rue et
la légitimité de la représentation
nationale.
Vous avez été, comme l'ensemble
des parlementaires, désigné par le
peuple pour pouvoir faire la loi,
amender la loi, voter la loi,
proposer ou vous opposer.
Je dis ça par rapport à certain
discours qui tendrait à compter et
à comparer la légitimité de l'un
et l'autre.
Nous avons un fonctionnement de
notre République démocratique qui
repose sur le respect des
institutions.
Dans la même veine, vous avez eu
l'occasion de soumettre et de
défendre ici même dans cet
hémicycle une motion visant à
proposer un référendum.
Vous avez été battus au vote.
Je ne doute pas une seconde que
vous ayez envie d'en contester le
résultat.
Vous avez eu cette opportunité.
Les parlementaires ont fait le
choix de se rassembler pour
examiner cet important projet de
loi pour l'avenir de notre modèle
social.
Vous déplorez, et moi aussi, le
fait que les débats n'aient pas pu
aller à leur terme, non pas parce
que la durée accordée aux débats
auraient été rabougris, il n'y a
jamais eu un temps de débat aussi
long sur une réforme des retraites
dans la Ve République que le temps
accordé dans cet hémicycle ainsi
qu'au Sénat, avec plus de 100
heures au Sénat, et les sénateurs
se réunissent jour et nuit pour
pouvoir adopter, déjà jusqu'à
l'article 6.
Ils vont entamer le fameux article
7 permettant aux débats
démocratiques de se poursuivre.
Nous respectons la contestation
sociale sous toutes ses formes,
manifestations, grèves, et nous
rappelons notre ambition de
réformer le pays, c'est-à-dire
aussi éviter que ce pays soit
paralysé, et que nous puissions
avancer collectivement.
- Emeric Salmon: Votre entêtement
est un message clair pour les
Français.
S'ils souhaitent un retour en
arrière sur ce projet de loi, ils
n'ont qu'un seul moyen: voter
Marine Le Pen en 2027.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à madame Pascale
Martin.
- Pascale Martin: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Madame la Première ministre, vous
avez affirmé hier en interview que
la volonté du gouvernement était
d'atteindre l'égalité salariale et
qu'il fallait se battre pour
l'obtenir.
La réforme des retraites pénalise
les femmes et pénalise leur
travail.
De l'aveu même de monsieur le
ministre du Travail, je le cite:
"Le débat sur la retraite pour les
femmes est extrêmement compliqué."
A la veille de la Journée
internationale du droit des femmes
et 40 ans après la loi majeure,
les femmes touchent toujours en
moyenne un quart de salaire en
moins que les hommes.
Elles sont toujours contraintes au
temps partiel et aux carrières
hachées.
Selon vous, les femmes peuvent
aujourd'hui concilier vie
professionnelle et vie familiale.
Ah bon?
Pourquoi les jeunes mères
sont-elles si souvent contraintes
de passer à temps partiel?
Pourquoi les femmes
s'appauvrissent lorsqu'elles
deviennent mères?
Pourquoi est-ce que votre
gouvernement ne fait rien pour
améliorer l'accès à l'emploi des
mères?
Où sont les places en crèche dont
nous avons besoin?
Le report de l'âge de la retraite
touchera plus fortement les femmes
que les hommes.
Rien n'est clair sur les
dispositifs pouvant atténuer ces
effets.
Alors que la droite sénatoriale
semble bien décidée à intégrer des
politiques natalistes rétrogrades
et sexistes à cette réforme, le
gouvernement remet ce débat au
prochain budget de la Sécurité
sociale.
J'ai évoqué plusieurs exemples,
notamment celui de Pascaline, 52
ans, au chômage, et désespérée par
le refus de l'embaucher des
employeurs.
D'autres femmes m'ont dit qu'elles
vivaient la même situation.
Mensonge après mensonge, les
femmes sont dans la rue, parce
qu'elles n'en peuvent plus.
Les hommes sont avec elles, car
ils n'en peuvent plus non plus.
Vous bloquez le pays, aujourd'hui.
Les femmes vont moins perdre que
prévu, mais elles vont perdre
quand même.
Pouvons-nous compter sur votre
engagement pour qu'enfin, les
femmes puissent vivre dignement de
leur travail?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Olivier Dussopt.
- Olivier Dussopt: Madame la
députée, finalement, nous pouvons
tomber d'accord sur un point:
l'égalité professionnelle entre
les femmes et les hommes reste un
objectif et un défi.
Beaucoup a été fait, par ce
gouvernement et ceux qui l'ont
précédé, pour l'accès des femmes à
l'emploi.
Beaucoup a été fait pour l'accès
des femmes à l'éducation.
C'est une marche de l'histoire
qu'il faut accélérer.
Dans le précédent quinquennat,
dans celui qui a précédé, dans
celui encore avant, les majorités
qui se sont succédées ont adopté
des textes permettant d'apporter
leur pierre à la construction de
l'égalité professionnelle entre
femmes et hommes.
Protestations
Je vous ai écouté, madame.
A l'occasion de chacune de ces
politiques, l'objectif a toujours
été le même: faire en sorte que
l'égalité soit au rendez-vous.
Puisque vous avez évoqué la
question des retraites, j'apporte
deux précisions.
Notre système de retraite, aussi
complexe soit-il, n'est pas un
système de retraite injuste avec
les femmes.
Aucune règle du système de
retraite ne discrimine les femmes
ou les hommes.
Notre système de retraite calcule
la pension d'un assuré ou d'une
assurée et tient compte de tout ce
qui a été cotisé tout au long de
la vie.
Il faut donc travailler sur
l'égalité professionnelle.
Je voulais souligner autre chose.
Avec cette réforme des retraites,
nous demandons un effort aux
Françaises et aux Français, qui
consiste à travailler un peu plus
pour garantir le système par
répartition.
Quand vous regardez l'étude
d'impact, la répartition de cet
effort entre les femmes et les
hommes, c'est 50-50.
Nous y avons veillé.
Nous travaillons pour cela.
J'ai une interrogation quand je
vous écoute.
Si vous êtes aussi attaché à
l'égalité professionnelle que
cela, pourquoi est-ce que votre
famille politique n'a jamais
soutenu les propositions de loi
portées par cette majorité pour
améliorer l'égalité?
Jamais vous ne les avez soutenues.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Hervé
Saulignac.
- Hervé Saulignac: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Le président de la République a
annoncé à la surprise générale
qu'il présidera demain un hommage
à la mémoire de Gisèle Halimi, à
l'occasion de la Journée
internationale des droits des
femmes.
Cette initiative a suscité
beaucoup de réactions,
d'incompréhension et même parfois
de colère.
Madame la Première ministre, si
Gisèle Halimi était encore des
nôtres, elle serait sûrement aux
côtés de celles et ceux qui
battent le pavé pour dénoncer une
réforme dont les premières
victimes seront les femmes.
Nombre de ses proches dénoncent
une instrumentalisation politique
et une opération de communication
grossière.
Gisèle Halimi a mené tant de
combats que nul ne peut l'enfermer
dans une cause unique, mais chacun
sait qu'elle a surtout défendu
avec acharnement la dignité des
femmes et des peuples.
Chacun sait combien son engagement
force le respect et l'admiration
de millions de Françaises et de
Français.
Chacun sait que les batailles qui
furent les siennes ont contribué à
faire grandir les idéaux de la
République.
Dans ces conditions, Gisèle Halimi
mérite mieux qu'un hommage en
forme de provocation.
La seule reconnaissance qui soit à
la hauteur de son engagement
serait de décider, enfin, de son
entrée au Panthéon.
Le président de la République doit
mettre fin à des atermoiements qui
sont vécus comme du mépris par
ceux qui ont la conviction que la
place de cette femme au parcours
de vie exceptionnelle se trouve
légitimement aux côtés de celles
et ceux qui sont l'honneur de la
France.
Les tergiversations du président
de la République ne sont pas
recevables.
Pas une femme, pas un homme qui ne
se soient tout entier consacrés à
tant de grandes causes ne peuvent
prétendre au consensus.
C'est dans ce temple de tous les
dieux qu'il convient désormais de
faire entrer cette grande femme.
C'est donc avec solennité que je
vous demande, madame la Première
ministre, si vous allez enfin
favoriser l'entrée au Panthéon de
Gisèle Halimi.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à madame Isabelle
Rome, ministre chargée de
l'Egalité entre les femmes et les
hommes.
- Isabelle Rome: Merci.
Monsieur le député, je vous
remercie de votre question.
Le 8 mars, Journée internationale
des droits des femmes, est une
occasion, chaque année, de
constater que le combat pour
l'égalité entre les femmes et les
hommes restent d'actualité.
Face à la montée de la pensée
conservatrice, nous devons
protéger nos concitoyens et nos
concitoyennes, protéger leurs
droits les plus fondamentaux en
rendant un hommage national à
Gisèle Halimi.
Le président de la République a
choisi d'honorer une femme de
combats, une pionnière du
féminisme.
Une avocate courageuse dont la
plaidoirie au procès de Bobigny
restera gravée dans le marbre de
nos mémoires.
L'avancée sociétale fondamentale
pour les droits des femmes que
constitue l'accès à l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse mérite,
elle aussi, d'être gravée dans le
marbre de notre plus puissant
texte républicain.
C'est ainsi que nous protégerons
nos filles de toutes les idées
rétrogrades qui pourraient, un
jour, revenir dans notre
République.
Le plan en faveur de l'égalité que
je présenterai demain aux côtés de
la Première ministre a été élaboré
dans cet esprit, autour de quatre
axes: la lutte contre les
violences, l'égalité économique,
la santé des femmes et la culture
de l'égalité.
Je pense que Gisèle Halimi aurait
apprécié ce plan.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à madame Charlotte
Parmentier-Lecocq.
- Charlotte Parmentier-Lecocq:
...
Je veux parler de la prise en
compte des congés parentaux qui
bénéficiera très majoritairement
aux femmes.
Je veux parler de la prise en
compte des congés proches aidants
qui bénéficiera également très
majoritairement aux femmes.
De plus, la majorité, au travers
de plusieurs amendements, portés
notamment par certains de mes
collègues, ainsi que par les
groupes MoDem et Horizons,
souhaite enrichir le texte.
Nous espérons que les débats au
Sénat permettront de concrétiser
ses avancées.
De nouvelles pistes sont également
à l'étude, notamment celle d'une
sur quatre pour les femmes ayant
eu un enfant et atteint un nombre
suffisant de trimestres avant
l'âge de départ à la retraite.
Pouvez-vous, sur ce point, nous
indiquer l'avis du gouvernement?
Nous le savons, les retraites des
femmes sont moins élevées parce
qu'elles sont le reflet de
carrières moins bien rémunérées et
souvent impactées par leur vie
familiale.
Pouvez-vous, monsieur le ministre,
nous indiquer quelles mesures vous
envisagez de mettre en oeuvre pour
poursuivre le combat contre les
inégalités salariales entre les
hommes et les femmes et pour
permettre aux femmes d'accéder aux
mêmes carrières que les hommes?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Olivier
Dussopt.
- Olivier Dussopt: Madame la
députée, vous m'interrogez sur la
situation des femmes au moment du
départ à la retraite, et notamment
sur ce que nous voulons faire pour
faire en sorte que l'égalité
professionnelle soit au
rendez-vous afin de réduire et
ainsi de réduire ces inégalités.
Le texte que nous présentons
prévoit un certain nombre de
mesures.
Je regrette que l'Assemblée n'ait
pu les examiner.
Le fait que nous souhaitions créer
une assurance vieillesse pour les
aidants , car nous savons que ce
sont souvent des femmes...
Des amendements portés par la
majorité, je pense à l'amendement
sur l'intégration des indemnités
journalières d'avant 2012...
Je pense à l'amendement du groupe
Horizons, faire en sorte de mieux
tenir compte des difficultés liées
à la perte d'un enfant ou au deuil
d'un enfant en bas âge avec les
conséquences que cela a
aujourd'hui sur le maintien de la
majoration de 10% pour le
troisième enfant, autant de sujets
que, j'espère, le Sénat viendra
concrétiser.
La majorité sénatoriale a proposé
un dispositif que nous regarderons
avec beaucoup de bienveillance.
De plus en plus de femmes ont, au
moment du départ à la retraite,
acquis des trimestres au titre de
leur carrière professionnelle.
La majorité sénatoriale propose
que, d'une part, les femmes ayant
une carrière hachée puissent
continuer à bénéficier de ces
trimestres pour éviter les
décotes, et, en même temps, celle
qui pourraient avoir atteint le
nombre de trimestres cotisés
puissent obtenir une décote qui
puisse devenir une surcote de la
pension.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Alexandre Vincendet.
- Alexandre Vincendet: Merci,
madame la présidente.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
Christophe Béchu.
Monsieur le ministre, le 1er
janvier 2023, la zone à faible
émission du Grand Lyon est entrée
en vigueur pour les voitures des
particuliers après une période
pédagogique de quatre mois.
La cause affichée est
indiscutable, mais combattre les
particules fines ne peut se faire
au détriment des plus modestes,
des travailleurs qui se lèvent
tôt, qui sont les grands oubliés
de cette politique punitive.
Les classes populaires ne polluent
pas volontairement.
Elles ne peuvent pas faire
autrement.
On ne pollue pas volontairement
quand on habite en banlieue.
quand la métropole de Lyon ajourne
l'extension des lignes de métro.
Quelle hypocrisie de vouloir
sanctionner les plus modestes, qui
ne peuvent pas s'acheter une
voiture électrique, au risque de
les reléguer dans les banlieues en
leur interdisant l'entrée dans les
grandes villes, y compris pour
aller travailler.
Face à la mobilisation d'une
grande partie de la population et
des élus locaux, la métropole du
Grand Lyon a annoncé ralentir la
cadence par rapport au calendrier
initial, mais ce n'est que
reporter le problème.
Que comptez-vous faire pour mettre
fin à la sourde colère qui gronde
face à cette écologie punitive qui
creuse des inégalités sociales
ainsi que dans des centaines de
villes moyennes?
Il ne faut pas que ces zones à
faible émission deviennent lieu
d'assignation à résidence.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur
Christophe Béchu.
- Christophe Béchu: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Mesdames et messieurs les députés,
monsieur le député, j'aimerais
vous remercier pour la manière
dont vous avez commencé à poser la
question.
Le combat contre les particules
fines n'a pas de frontières.
Nous nous retrouvons dans ce
combat.
Je veux vous rappeler que ces
zones à faible émission, ce n'est
pas une invention française.
Il y a des difficultés
potentielles pour les plus
modestes.
Il y en a aussi, compte tenu de
cette pollution.
On sait que les premières victimes
de cette pollution atmosphérique,
ceux qui sont en première ligne,
ce sont les personnes âgées, les
enfants et les plus mal-logés.
Votre question porte sur les
conditions d'application à
l'intérieur de la métropole de
Lyon.
Vous me donnez l'occasion de
revenir sur l'épisode de
communication qui a eu lieu il y a
quelques semaines dans cette
métropole avec le président de la
métropole expliquant qu'il était
obligé de renoncer à cette
ambition.
De quoi s'agit-il?
Il a annoncé, pour montrer que la
métropole de Lyon était
certainement la plus pure, la plus
radicale de France, il n'y aurait
pas seulement une date pour les
critères 5, 3 et 4, mais même pour
les critères 2, alors que rien
dans la loi n'est prévu pour ce
type de véhicule.
Je vais plus loin.
La loi ne dit pas que vous avez
l'obligation d'interdire des
véhicules.
Si vous dépasser les seuils de
pollution de l'air fixé au niveau
européen, vous avez un calendrier
progressif.
Si vous ne les dépassez pas, vous
n'avez aucune obligation
d'interdire des véhicules dans les
centres-villes.
Cela explique à la fois les cas
d'exonération et la politique
constante du gouvernement dans ce
domaine.
Pour être clair, que ceux qui ont
décidé de faire de l'écologie un
prétexte électoral ne viennent pas
se plaindre d'être rattrapés par
la réalité de leurs concitoyens.
- Alexandre Vincendet: Merci.
Simplement, il est important de
voir que, s'il y a des
applications qui sont plus
strictes encore que la loi, avec
justement, à Lyon, le fait
d'interdire les véhicules critères
2, nous avons une bombe sociale
devant nous, car nous empêcherons
des milliers de personnes
précaires de venir travailler dans
les métropoles et nous
continuerons à fracturer nos
territoires.
Cela n'est pas acceptable.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Pierre
Dharréville.
- Pierre Dharréville: Madame la
Première ministre, c'est le
moment.
C'est maintenant.
Peut-être pas tout de suite,
peut-être dans quelques heures,
quoique.
Finalement, l'Assemblée nationale
serait un lieu pour faire vos
annonces.
C'est un grand jour de grève.
Des femmes et des hommes
manifestent massivement, à
nouveau, dans tout le pays, contre
la réforme des retraites.
N'allez pas croire que cela
réponde à une sorte de folklore.
Celles et ceux qui refusent votre
projet sont déterminés.
Ils et elles ont bien compris les
enjeux.
Ils et elles veulent être
respectés.
Vous n'avez convaincu personne.
Ils se sont presque tous et
toutes, dans cet hémicycle, et les
partisans de cette réforme...
Il y en a quelques dizaines au
Sénat.
Il y a le président de la
République aussi, à l'Elysée, qui
regarde défiler les pancartes
aujourd'hui.
Peut-être également le bureau
exécutif du MEDEF, même s'il n'ose
pas trop s'en vanter.
Vous avez fait les fonds de tiroir
des arguments du sauve-qui-peut,
de la dernière chance.
La réforme serait soi-disant une
réforme de gauche.
Le mouvement social nuirait au
climat.
Vous avez perdu, madame la
Première ministre, la bataille des
retraites.
Votre réforme est inutile, injuste
et fondamentalement régressive.
C'est deux ans de plus ou des
pensions en berne.
Vous avez perdu la bataille des
retraites.
Vous devez l'admettre.
Il n'y a pas d'autre issue.
Vous devez retirer le texte.
Ne continuez pas à tenter le coup.
Arrêtez le passage en force.
Vous semblez en faire une sorte de
preuve d'autorité.
Si vous voulez renouer le lien
avec le pays, il faut montrer que
vous savez écouter.
Comment voyez-vous la suite?
Comment pouvons-nous vous aider à
annoncer au plus vite le retrait?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Olivier Dussopt.
- Olivier Dussopt: Merci.
Monsieur le député, vous nous
interrogez sur la réforme des
retraites.
J'ai bien compris que vous
appeliez au retrait.
Je crains de vous décevoir.
Pourquoi faisons-nous cette
réforme?
Nous savons que cette réforme est
difficile.
Nous la faisons parce que cette
réforme est nécessaire.
Elle est nécessaire car le système
de retraite est déficitaire.
Il est déficitaire lourdement,
structurellement, avec 12,5
milliards de déficit en 2027, 20
milliards d'euros par an à partir
de 2035.
Cette réforme est nécessaire pour
préserver notre système de
retraite par répartition.
Elle est difficile, parce que
c'est une réforme qui demande des
efforts aux Français, avec deux
ans travaillés en plus, pas pour
tous, progressivement, en tenant
compte de la pénibilité, des
carrières longues, des inégalités
de carrière.
Nous faisons en sorte que cet
effort soit le plus justement
réparti.
C'est en cela que la réforme est
juste.
D'abord, parce que l'effort est
justement réparti, et puis parce
que cet effort créé des droits en
termes de meilleure protection
face aux carrières hachées, en
termes d'amélioration de la
situation des femmes et des
hommes.
Vous me dites que nous sommes
allés chercher des arguments le
plus loin possible.
Nous ne sommes pas allés très
loin.
Nous avons regardé autour de nous.
Nous avons vu que, dans tous les
pays qui nous entourent, qu'ils
soient libéraux ou
sociaux-démocrates, les
perspectives de l'âge de départ
ont déjà été relevées.
Si j'étais malicieux, je vous
dirais que, même en Espagne, c'est
une ministre du Travail communiste
qui a mis en oeuvre une réforme
votée qui fait que l'âge officiel
est fixée à 66 ans.
Nous ne sommes pas isolés.
Nous avons un déficit
démographique, un déficit
financier.
Nous avons besoin de faire cette
réforme.
Le Sénat va continuer à examiner
la réforme.
Vous serez à nouveau saisis à
l'Assemblée nationale.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
- Pierre Dharréville: Vous n'êtes
pas raisonnable.
Il va falloir changer de réponse.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Jean-Louis Bricout.
- Jean-Louis Bricout: Ma question
s'adresse à la Première ministre.
Ouvriers, employés,
fonctionnaires, étudiants: les
Français sont dans la rue.
Ils sont des milliers, et dans la
dignité.
Ils sont dans la rue contre votre
réforme, mais pas que.
Ils sont surtout excédés par vos
choix.
Ils sont excédés par votre manque
de considération et de respect.
Ils sont excédés par vos
politiques les plus injustes les
unes que les autres.
Ils sont excédés par le fait de
vous entendre ressasser que tout
va bien.
Les étudiants font la queue aux
Restos du Coeur.
L'inflation rend la vie de chacun
impossible.
Les banques alimentaires comptent
un tiers de bénéficiaires en plus,
dont 18% d'actifs.
Madame la Première ministre, je
vous parle de notre jeunesse, des
gens qui bossent et des petits
retraités.
Le monde du travail est excédé de
vous entendre dire que tout va
bien, qu'il va falloir encore
faire des efforts.
Votre réforme des retraites, c'est
l'injustice de trop.
Pourquoi faire payer aux seuls
travailleurs le prix de cette
réforme?
Pour qui?
Pour une petite minorité de
privilégiés?
C'est non.
Votre dogmatisme et vos
certitudes, ça suffit.
Un peuple qui a bâti son histoire
sur un idéal de justice s'est levé
contre cette réforme.
On n'avait pas le droit de lui
opposer un débat bafoué, des
mesures législatives tronquées,
des 49.3
en bis repetita, de paralyser la
France et de témoigner au peuple
du mépris de la souffrance.
Quand allez-vous retirer votre
réforme?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
- Olivier Dussopt: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Monsieur le député Jean-Louis
Bricout, il n'y a jamais de bon
moment pour faire une réforme des
retraites.
Vous l'avez entendu des dizaines
de fois.
Il n'y a jamais de bon moment.
Personne n'a jamais le courage de
faire cette réforme.
Je l'ai dit il y a un instant.
Il y a une nécessité d'avancer, de
faire.
Nous sommes dans une situation qui
fait de la démographie pour la
réforme.
Dans les années 70, il y avait
trois cotisants pour un retraité.
Une perspective déficitaire
structurelle et durable.
Que devons-nous faire?
Attendre?
Si nous ne faisons pas la réforme,
le déficit continue de se creuser.
Si nous attendons deux ans, trois
ou quatre ans de plus, on
retournera à l'équilibre
.
pris par le président de la
République à l'occasion de la
dernière campagne présidentielle.
La réforme que nous présentons a
évolué au fil du temps pour mieux
protéger les plus fragiles, mieux
prendre en compte les carrières
hachées, l'usure professionnelle
et la prévenir.
Nous l'avons fait avec la
concertation.
Nous n'avons pas surmonté tous les
désaccords, mais nous continuons à
avancer.
Vous dites que ce n'est pas le
moment car il y a d'autres
difficultés.
Il y a des difficultés de pouvoir
d'achat, d'inflation, mais où
étiez-vous?
Pourquoi n'avez-vous pas voté les
textes budgétaires qui
permettaient d'aider les Français?
Nous protégeons leur pouvoir
d'achat.
Garantissons l'avenir du système
de retraite.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Monsieur
Jean-Louis Bricout?
- Jean-Louis Bricout: Je suis
désolé, je n'appelle pas ça du
courage que de sacrifier le régime
social de nos ouvriers pendant
deux ans.
Je pense que votre retraite, de
toute façon, il faut la retirer.
Ce n'est pas le bon tempo.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Monique Ibora.
- Monique Ibora: Ma question
s'adresse au ministre de la Santé
et de la Prévention.
De nombreux rapports et diverses
communications ont attiré
l'attention sur la nécessité de
prendre en compte le genre dans
nos politiques publiques en
matière de santé.
Il arrive en effet que les
politiques publiques soient
marquées par des préjugés et des
stéréotypes liés au genre et
influencent la prise en compte de
signes cliniques et retarde le
diagnostic nécessaire
sans lequel les stratégies de
prévention et de traitement ne
peuvent être définies.
Il faut nuancer.
L'ostéoporose, maladie féminine,
touche aussi les hommes.
Des stéréotypes qu'ils faut
dénoncer.
Les conditions de vie sociale,
économique et les facteurs
environnementaux doivent être pris
en compte sachant qu'ils impactent
de manière différente les hommes
et les femmes, ces dernières étant
plus touchées par la précarité
notamment.
Partant de ces constats, comment
aller plus loin pour cette prise
en compte du genre et du sexe dans
l'élaboration de nos politiques
publiques?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à François Braun.
- François Braun: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Madame la députée, la santé des
femmes est un enjeu majeur pour ce
gouvernement, comme l'a rappelé
Isabelle Rome.
C'est aussi une préoccupation
constante des députés de la
majorité et d'autres députés sur
ces bancs.
Permettez-moi de rappeler quelques
mesures qui ont été prises
récemment concernant la santé des
femmes.
Dans le cadre du droit
reproductif, la prise en charge à
100% de la contraception d'urgence
pour toutes les femmes.
Dans ce cadre-là, la prise en
charge à 100% du dépistage sans
ordonnance des infections
sexuellement transmissibles pour
les hommes.
Le papillomavirus, le 28 février
dernier, avec le président de la
République, nous avons lancé la
campagne de vaccination des
garçons et des filles en cinquième
contre ce virus.
Il est le responsable de cancers
chez les hommes comme chez les
femmes.
Il est responsable de 100% du
cancer du col de l'utérus, qui tue
encore plus de 1000 femmes par an.
Cette vaccination ne permettra de
l'éradiquer.
Dans le cadre de la précarité
menstruelle, madame la Première
ministre a assuré le remboursement
par la Sécurité sociale des
protections réutilisables pour les
femmes de moins de 25 ans.
Au-delà, vous avez raison, il y a
un certain nombre de pathologies
pour lesquelles les symptômes chez
la femme sont mal connus.
La recherche nous permet de mieux
les connaître maintenant.
Il faut mieux les déployer et
mieux les apprendre sur le
territoire.
D'autres dispositifs nous
permettront de rentrer dans une
meilleure prise en charge des
couples.
Sur la prévention également, je ne
rappellerai pas les spécificités
des rendez-vous de prévention, car
c'est dans cette assemblée que
plusieurs amendements ont amené
une spécificité des rendez-vous de
prévention.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Ugo Bernalicis.
- Ugo Bernalicis: Madame la
Première ministre, en cette
journée de mobilisation, je vais
vous parler de blocage.
Il y a un an, vous refusiez la
proposition de loi que j'ai
défendue avec Jean-Luc Mélenchon
sur le blocage des prix sur le
modèle qui se pratique en
outre-mer.
Depuis, les prix des produits de
première nécessité et de l'énergie
ont explosé.
Bien loin des 5% d'inflation dont
vous vous targuez.
30% pour la farine, 25% pour le
riz, 33% pour les steaks hachés
surgelés, 13% pour le lait.
Les prix du gaz, du pétrole et de
l'électricité sont en hausse.
Face à l'inflation, vous proposez
de faire confiance à la grande
distribution.
Ca me rappelle l'histoire avec
Total, quand vous aviez demandé
qu'il fasse un effort.
Résultat, des milliards d'euros de
profits.
Plutôt qu'un panier anti-inflation
qui ressemble plus à un coup
d'épée dans l'eau.
Je vous propose une solution pour
débloquer la situation.
Il faut bloquer les prix.
La pauvreté s'aggrave, la
fréquentation des Restos du Coeur
est en hausse
en France.
Ca continue.
Vous ne pouvez plus refuser d'agir
en renvoyant encore l'idée que
l'Etat ne pourrait rien.
Il faut bloquer les prix.
Les boulangers sont en mode
survie.
On nous annonce un mars rouge pour
l'inflation.
Il faut sortir de vos formules
publicitaires.
Il faut agir pendant que les gens
bloquent le pays contre la réforme
des retraites.
Il faut bloquer les prix pour ne
pas ajouter à une crise sociale
une crise humanitaire.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Bruno Le Maire.
- Bruno Le Maire: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Monsieur le député Ugo Bernalicis,
dans le fond, à tous les problèmes
économiques de la nation
française, vous apportez toujours
les deux mêmes réponses: le
blocage des prix ou la taxation
des gens.
Nous sommes opposés aux deux.
La taxation des gens, car je pense
que nos compatriotes en ont assez
de payer toujours plus d'impôts et
de taxes.
Le blocage des prix, car ça veut
dire tout simplement le
rationnement de nos compatriotes
sur des biens de première
nécessité.
Nous avons pris des mesures qui
nous permettent d'avoir un des
taux d'inflation les plus faibles
de la zone euro.
Nous avons mis en place un
bouclier sur le prix de
l'électricité.
Nous avons mis en place un
bouclier sur les prix du gaz.
Nous avons mis en place une
indemnité carburant et le résultat
de tout ça, c'est que l'inflation
qui touche tous les pays
développés au monde, les
Etats-Unis, tous les pays
européens...
Il y a un pays qui s'en sort mieux
que les autres, grâce aux mesures
prises par le gouvernement, par
cette majorité, c'est la France.
Vous devriez vous en féliciter!
Nos compatriotes qui font leurs
courses jugeront.
Ils verront qu'avec ce trimestre
pendant trois mois, ils auront
droit à des prix cassés.
Pendant trois mois, les
distributeurs vont faire des
efforts sur leurs marges.
C'est à hauteur de plusieurs
centaines de millions d'euros.
C'est pour que nos compatriotes
aient les prix les plus bas
possibles.
Ils retrouveront un logo tricolore
anti-inflation.
Ils verront dans leur panier que
leurs prix baissent réellement.
Nous préférons garantir la
sécurité de l'approvisionnement et
les prix les plus bas possibles à
ce que vous proposez, c'est-à-dire
le blocage et le rationnement.
Nous avons également permis aux
distributeurs dans trois mois de
renégocier les prix avec la grande
industrie de façon à ce que les
prix continuent à baisser dans les
mois qui viennent.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Vous n'avez
plus de temps, monsieur Ugo
Bernalicis.
Merci.
La parole est à Julien Odoul.
- Julien Odoul: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
Dupond-Moretti, garde des Sceaux.
Monsieur le ministre, dans un
récent communiqué, le syndicat de
la magistrature de Mayotte a
exprimé son rejet des lois de la
République qui permettent de
lutter contre l'immigration
clandestine.
Au mépris de la sécurité de nos
compatriotes de Mayotte confrontés
à une criminalité record et à
l'invasion comorienne, ce syndicat
d'extrême gauche a dénoncé le lien
pourtant officiel, avéré et
documenté, entre l'ultraviolence
et l'immigration.
Alors que monsieur Darmanin
s'apprête à lancer une nouvelle
opération de communication pour
les clandestins, certains juges
osent parler de "chasse aux
sans-papiers" et de
"tout-répressif", allant même
jusqu'à dire que la politique
pénale est décidée par le
ministère de l'Intérieur.
Monsieur le ministre, devant la
représentation nationale,
pouvez-vous condamner clairement
les déclarations antirépublicaines
de la magistrature et garantir que
la loi de la République s'applique
partout et en toutes circonstances
sur l'ensemble du territoire
national?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Eric
Dupond-Moretti.
- Eric Dupond-Moretti:
Monsieur le député Julien Odoul,
les propos du syndicat de la
magistrature n'engagent que le
syndicat de la magistrature.
D'ailleurs, je voudrais vous
rappeler qu'un élu de Mayotte a
vivement protesté pour dire un
certain nombre de choses et
rappeler ce que sont les valeurs
de la République.
Je rappelle également que les
magistrats sont tenus à un devoir
de réserve.
Je rappelle enfin que le garde des
Sceaux, dans le système
démocratique qui est le nôtre...
Vous faites non de la tête, nous
ne sommes pas en Hongrie.
On ne peut pas intervenir pour
dire aux magistrats comment ils
doivent s'exprimer.
Chacun en pense ce qu'il doit en
penser.
Sur Mayotte, je voudrais vous dire
que nous avons envoyé un nouveau
service de greffe, des nouveaux
greffiers et des magistrats.
Nous avons inventé la brigade de
l'urgence.
Je voudrais simplement vous dire
que nous avons fait tout cela
alors que vous n'avez pas voté
pour.
- Julien Odoul: Votre réponse est
à l'image de votre politique
pénale: lamentable.
Allez-vous une bonne fois pour
toutes entendre les cris d'alarme
du peuple français à Mayotte?
Allez-vous une bonne fois pour
toutes protéger ce département
français de la submersion
migratoire et de la disparition?
Allez-vous une bonne fois pour
toute rétablir l'ordre la paix
pour nos compatriotes qui
subissent les meurtres à la
machette, le communautarisme
sauvage?
Les habitants de Mayotte ont le
coeur qui bat au rythme de la
Marseillaise.
Ils font massivement confiance à
Marine Le Pen depuis six ans pour
rester des Français.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Monsieur le
ministre?
- Eric Dupond-Moretti: Je ne suis
pas pour que les migrants meurent
aux frontières avec l'humanité qui
vous caractérise, monsieur Julien
Odoul.
Vous êtes comme ces commentateurs
de certaines chaînes d'information
en continu:
"Y a qu'à, faut qu'on".
chaque fois que je suis interpellé
par vous, il faut voter les
budgets.
C'est mieux que du bla-bla.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Francesca
Pasquini.
- Francesca Pasquini: Merci,
madame la présidente.
Elles s'appelaient Angélique,
Valérie, Eva, Elena, Catherine,
Manon, Magdalena, Marie, Camille,
Laurence, Séverine, Flora,
Valeria, Sophie, Marie-Antoinette,
Elisa, Joëlle, Cathy, Fatiha.
Ces prénoms, ce sont ceux des
femmes qui ont été massacrées par
leur compagnon ou ex-compagnon
depuis le 1er janvier 2023.
Cinq restent encore anonymes.
Je veux, à la veille du 8 mars,
leur rendre hommage dans cette
enceinte.
Si j'arrive à les nommer une par
une dans le temps qui m'est
imparti, c'est uniquement parce
que nous ne sommes que débuts
mars.
A la fin de l'année, cette liste
n'aura fait que croître.
Les trois dernières femmes sont
décédées le week-end dernier en
l'espace de deux jours.
Deux d'entre elles avaient jamais
déposé plainte pour violences
conjugales.
Toutes ces femmes n'auraient pas
dû mourir.
La seule main qui peut arrêter
cette tuerie, c'est celle de notre
justice et de l'action publique.
Depuis 2017, la grande cause du
quinquennat est la lutte contre
les féminicides.
Pourtant, pas une année ne passe
sans que plus de 100 femmes soient
tuées sous les coups de leur
compagnon.
Nous ne pouvons plus nous
contenter des effets d'annonce.
Il faut un plan complet de prise
en charge globale de ce sujet, une
remise à plat des approches des
violences familiales.
Vous rencontrerez prochainement le
Premier ministre espagnol.
Nous devons nous inspirer
concrètement de ce qui se fait et
fonctionne dans ce pays.
Madame la Première ministre,
allez-vous accéder aux demandes
des associations et investir à
hauteur de ce qui serait
nécessaire?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Eric
Dupond-Moretti.
- Eric Dupond-Moretti: Merci,
madame la présidente.
Le premier responsable d'un
féminicide, madame la députée, ne
vous en déplaise, c'est son
auteur.
Les Espagnols, que vous prenez en
modèle et en exemple, que j'ai
rencontrés, ils ont un seuil de
féminicides en deçà duquel ils ne
sont pas défendus.
Cela ne nous condamne pas au
fatalisme.
Nous ne sommes pas fatalistes.
Là encore, la critique, le
bla-bla, c'est facile.
Le nombre de jugements en matière
de violences conjugales a doublé,
madame la députée, de 2017 à 2021.
Le nombre de condamnations en 2017
était inférieur à celui de 2021.
La réponse judiciaire est plus
rapide.
Les procédures de
déferrement ont augmenté de 182%.
205% entre 2017 et 2021.
Réponse pénale plus ferme,
augmentation des condamnations,
plus 100% entre 2017 et 2022.
Plus 153% pour les ordonnances.
C'est facile de dire que le
gouvernement ne fait rien après
avoir égrené ces féminicide.
Ce n'est pas vrai.
En 2006, le nombre de féminicides
dans ce pays, c'est 179.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Chantal Bouloux.
- Chantal Bouloux: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Mesdames et messieurs les
ministres, chers collègues, ma
question s'adresse à madame la
ministre de l'Europe et des
Affaires étrangères.
Ce mercredi 8 mars se tiendra la
Journée internationale du droit
des femmes.
D'Olympe de Gouges à Simone Weil,
en passant par Simone de Beauvoir,
notre nation a toujours été à
l'avant-garde de la pensée et des
combats féministes.
Au mois d'avril 2022, le président
de la République a réaffirmé
vouloir faire de l'égalité entre
les femmes et les hommes la grande
cause de son quinquennat.
Notre majorité s'engage dans sa
volonté d'inscrire le droit à
l'IVG dans la constitution.
L'actualité nous démontre que
partout où le climat politique se
durcit, les droits des femmes sont
les premiers bafoués.
En Afghanistan, où le régime
taliban interdit l'expression de
la libre expression des femmes...
L'Ukraine, où les Nations Unies
attestent que les femmes sont
victimes de violences sexuelles
insupportables de la part de
l'agresseur russe.
Fidèle à son histoire, la France
peut et doit continuer à jouer un
rôle dans la protection des
femmes.
Madame la ministre, à la veille de
cette journée du 8 mars,
pouvez-vous réaffirmer ici que la
diplomatie française gardienne
historique de la défense des
droits de l'homme dans le monde
continuera de s'attacher tout
autant à la protection des droits
de la femme?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Catherine Colonna.
- Catherine Colonna: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Madame la députée, merci de votre
question, car la France continuera
résolument de se lever pour le
droit des femmes.
Ils sont menacés dans trop de
régions du monde.
En Iran, les femmes engagées pour
la liberté ont été réprimées.
J'ai remis à titre posthume à une
famille le prix franco-allemand
des droits de l'homme.
C'est en Afghanistan bien sûr
et en Ukraine.
Nous continuerons de porter un
message public fort, comme je l'ai
fait à Genève, il y a quelques
jours.
Nous continuerons d'apporter une
réponse ciblée, mais aussi
d'accroître la pression.
Aujourd'hui, veille du 8 mars,
l'Union Européenne vient de
sanctionner des responsables de
violations contre les droits des
femmes.
En Russie, en Afghanistan, en
Iran, en Birmanie, en Syrie,
au Soudan du Sud, tous les
responsables qui ont porté
atteinte aux droits des femmes
et que nous sanctionnons
par le gel de leurs avoirs
et l'interdiction de travailler.
Une des personnes concernées,
c'est le ministre afghan
"du Vice de la Vertu".
Je ferai, comme la Première
ministre, de nouvelles annonces
demain à l'occasion du 8 mars.
Vous pourrez voir dès aujourd'hui
sur les grilles du Quai d'Orsay
des photos des combattantes de la
liberté.
C'est le programme Marianne.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Marie-Noëlle
Battistel.
- Marie-Noëlle Battistel: Merci,
madame la présidente.
Demain 8 mars, nous célébrerons la
Journée internationale des droits
des femmes et de la lutte pour
l'égalité.
Partout en France dans le monde,
les acteurs institutionnels,
associatifs, économiques, les
citoyens vont se mobiliser pour
dire leur engagement pour
l'égalité entre les femmes et les
hommes, et marquer le chemin qu'il
reste à faire.
Les déclarations ministérielles et
présidentielles ne feront aucune
fausse note dans le concert des
bonnes intentions de ceux qui
veulent agir pour que les droits
des femmes soient renforcés.
Les grandes déclarations ne
suffisent pas.
Elles sont louables mais ne
résiste pas au poids des faits et
des intentions.
Les femmes paieront un lourd
tribut avec la réforme.
Le ministre Franck Riester
lui-même l'a reconnu.
Il a raison.
Les femmes qui ont des carrières
ininterrompues doivent travailler
plus longtemps.
Les bénéfices des trimestres de
maternité seront annulés par le
report de l'âge à 64 ans.
Et si finalement l'égalité
salariale permettant d'augmenter
les cotisations était une partie
de la solution?
Plutôt que d'augmenter la durée de
cotisation, agissez en permettant
aux femmes de gagner autant que
les hommes, et ainsi de cotiser
davantage, ce qui serait davantage
une forme de progrès de gauche.
Madame la Première ministre, ma
question est simple: le
gouvernement va-t-il rejoindre le
rang de ceux qui veulent faire de
l'égalité femme-comme une réalité
en renonçant à cette réforme
inutile et un juste?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Olivier Dussopt.
- Olivier Dussopt: Merci, madame
la présidente.
J'ai eu l'occasion de rappeler
plusieurs choses tout à l'heure.
La réforme que nous présentons
permet de mieux prendre en compte
le caractère
haché de la carrière de beaucoup
de femmes.
On intègre des trimestres cotisés
au titre de l'assurance
vieillesse.
Nous apportons une première
réponse.
Nous soutenons l'amendement
soutenu par Philippe Vigier.
Nous aidons aussi au
rétablissement et à l'amélioration
de la retraite des femmes.
Nous faisons en sorte, madame la
députée, que la pension minimum,
telle que nous la mettons en
oeuvre, puisse venir protéger plus
fortement celles et ceux qui ont
des carrières hachées.
Les deux tiers des bénéficiaires,
les deux tiers des 200.000
retraités
à la retraite la moins valorisée
sont des femmes.
En 2030, l'effort qui est demandé
est parfaitement réparti.
Nous allons aller plus loin.
Avec le soutien de la majorité
sénatoriale et présidentielle,
nous ferons en sorte que les
femmes puissent bénéficier d'une
surcote.
Cela permettra aux femmes d'éviter
la décote.
C'est quelque chose d'important
sur lequel nous voulons
travailler.
Les femmes ont plus souvent besoin
des hommes pour éviter la décote.
Pour cela, nous avons, pour la
première fois, voulu garder la
décote à 67 ans pour amener les
femmes à aller plus loin.
Qu'est-ce qui fait une carrière
hachée et incomplète?
C'est la durée de cotisation.
En 2013, nous avons voté
l'allongement.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Marie-Noëlle
Battistel?
- Marie-Noëlle Battistel: Je
constate que 11 milliards seront
supportés par les femmes et 7 par
les hommes pour atteindre les 18
milliards d'économies.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Didier Lemaire.
- Didier Lemaire: Madame la
présidente, ma question s'adresse
à monsieur le ministre de la
Transition écologique.
Chers collègues, en 2022, en
France, 700 communes étaient
concernées par des problèmes d'eau
potable.
Nous avions mis en place des
citernes.
Nous sommes aujourd'hui le 7 mars,
et plus de six départements sont
d'ores et déjà en vigilance
concernant la sécheresse
hivernale.
La semaine dernière, les premiers
incendies de forêt de 2023 ont eu
lieu.
Cela nous rappelle l'été
particulièrement douloureux que
nous avons traversé en 2022.
On annonce un été 2023 encore plus
difficile.
Plusieurs aberrations ont toujours
lieu.
Seules 1% des eaux usées sont
retraitées en France.
Il est toujours interdit
d'utiliser de l'eau de pluie dans
les sanitaires périscolaires et
les piscines ou les EHPAD.
Monsieur le ministre, je ne vous
cache pas d'être très inquiet.
J'ai appris au cours de ma
carrière de sapeur-pompier qu'en
matière de gestion de crise, la
chance n'a pas sa place, et que la
prévention reste son meilleur
atout.
Dans ma circonscription, une
initiative a été lancée en octobre
dernier sur le mois de l'eau.
Il permet de sensibiliser nos
concitoyens, mais aussi les élus,
agents communaux et gestionnaires
au rôle de l'eau.
Monsieur le ministre, je ne vous
demande pas de faire tomber la
pluie, mais en attendant que des
nuages gorgés d'eau ne se pointent
à l'horizon, que comptez-vous
faire face à ces nouveaux défis?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Christophe Béchu.
- Christophe Béchu: Madame la
présidente, monsieur le député, on
a vécu un été hors norme.
Plus de 700 communes privées d'eau
potable.
1260 rivières qui se sont
retrouvées en rupture
d'écoulement.
A la fin du mois de septembre,
nous avons, avec Agnès Firmin Le
Bodo, lancé les premières briques
du chantier de la planification
écologique qui aboutira à un plan
d'une cinquantaine de mesures
concrètes sur la qualité et la
quantité de gouvernance pour faire
en sorte de tenir compte de ce
qu'il s'est passé, mais pas
seulement.
Dans ce domaine, avec un volet
outre-mer...
Dans ce domaine, nous avons
également lancé une mission de
retour d'expérience confiée à
quatre inspections: ministère de
l'Agriculture, de la Santé, de
l'Ecologie, entre autres, pour
faire le point sur ce qui a marché
et sur ce qui n'a pas marché.
Dans la continuité, le 23 février,
nous avons réuni le comité
d'anticipation sécheresse.
Tous les préfets de département
étaient réunis hier.
Deux messages simples: d'abord, ne
pas hésiter à prendre des mesures
de restriction.
Nous sommes à la fois dans une
situation inédite, nous avons
abordé cette période avec un
niveau des nappes particulièrement
faible.
A date, nous sommes dans une
situation pire que l'année
dernière à la même époque.
C'est la raison pour laquelle plus
de 12 départements ont déjà des
arrêtés de vigilance ou d'alerte.
Cela ne va pas s'arrêter.
D'ici la fin du mois de mars, dans
tous les départements, les comités
ressources en eau vont se réunir.
Nous sommes donc pleinement
engagés là-dessus, sur le front
des incendies, il y a des mesures
qui ont été annoncées, la campagne
sur l'obligation légale de
débroussaillement...
Merci.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Ségolène
Amiot.
- Ségolène Amiot: Merci.
Monsieur le ministre Ndiaye, à
votre avis, quelle est la
profession déconsidérée et
maltraitée qui a connu à la fois
un déclassement salarial sans
équivalent avec une perte de 1%
par an depuis 40 ans et une hausse
sans précédent du niveau de
recrutement, du degré d'exigence
professionnel et la diversité de
ses missions?
Ce sont les enseignants et
enseignantes, bien sûr.
Enseignants qui sont parmi les
plus mal payés de l'OCDE et dont
les classes sont les plus chargées
d'Europe.
La profession porte les stigmates
de la brutalité du ministère de
Jean-Michel Blanquer, et vous,
vous avez été choisi pour tenter
de réparer les pots cassés.
Vous avez été choisi pour ce que
vous incarnez, mais sans que le
moindre détail n'ait été changé.
Ce décor est celui d'une logique
néolibérale en marche forcée
depuis 2017.
Celui d'un ministère des Finances
qui dicte sa loi à tous les
autres.
C'est ainsi que vous décidez de
supprimer un millier de postes
dans le premier degré à la rentrée
prochaine et des centaines dans le
second degré.
C'est ainsi que vous vous asseyez
sur la promesse du candidat Macron
de revaloriser sans condition de
10% tous les enseignants en
janvier 2023.
Alors, monsieur le ministre, je
vous le demande, comment
allez-vous ramener les syndicats
autour de la table des
négociations si vous n'avez que
des fausses promesses et des
polices privées, comme à
Clichy-sous-Bois, envoyées pour
casser du prof à leur offrir?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Pap
Ndiaye.
- Pap Ndiaye: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Madame la députée, le budget du
ministère de l'Education nationale
augmente de 6,5% cette année.
C'est une augmentation inédite.
Voilà pour ce qui concerne les
chiffres globaux de ce ministère
qui vont permettre une hausse de
rémunération des enseignants.
Contrairement à ce que vous
semblez croire, cette hausse de
rémunération a deux volets: un
volet inconditionnel, pour tous
les
enseignants, des néo-titulaires
jusqu'à ceux qui sont en fin de
carrière, et puis un volet assorti
de missions nouvelles,
facultatives, pour celles et ceux
qui choisiront de s'engager dans
cette voie.
Voilà pour ce qui concerne la
hausse des rémunérations.
Vous faites allusion à une réunion
technique qui a été interrompue
hier par les syndicats, ce qui est
regrettable, mais qui ne remet pas
en cause les négociations que nous
avons avec eux depuis le 18
janvier.
50 heures de négociations jusqu'à
présent.
Elles vont se poursuivre.
Nous avons des différends sur les
missions, mais cela fait partie de
l'ordinaire des échanges sincères
que nous avons avec les syndicats.
Madame la députée, je vous demande
de considérer les faits.
C'est d'abord une baisse des
effectifs scolaires que nous ne
compensons pas de manière
arithmétique, bien au contraire.
Le taux d'encadrement va
s'améliorer dès l'année prochaine.
C'est une augmentation de
rémunération des enseignants, mais
aussi des personnels de direction,
mais aussi des personnels
administratifs.
Voilà la réalité, voilà ce que
nous faisons.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
- Ségolène Amiot: Monsieur le
ministre, vous n'entendez pas, ou
vous n'écoutez pas.
Les enseignants demandent
l'égalité salariale entre les
hommes et les femmes, la
revalorisation salariale
ambitieuse et sans contrepartie de
tous les professionnels, les
moyens nécessaires pour instruire
dignement nos enfants.
Actuellement, vous êtes en train
de grossir les rangs des
manifestants de ce jour et de la
semaine avec les enseignants et
les enseignantes qui sont
légitimement en colère et qui
demandent bien plus que le retrait
de cette réforme des retraites.
- Pap Ndiaye: Madame la députée,
je pense que vous feriez mieux de
vous intéresser précisément et
sérieusement aux réformes
entreprises pour l'attractivité du
métier de professeur plutôt que
d'inciter nos élèves, sur un
réseau social douteux, à bloquer
les établissements au mépris de la
loi.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Eric
Poulliat.
- Eric Poulliat: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre de la Transformation
et de la Fonction publiques,
Stanislas Guerini.
En cette veille de 8 mars, je
souhaite attirer votre attention
sur la fonction des femmes
-- représentation des femmes dans
la fonction publique.
Premier employeur de France, elle
se doit d'être exemplaire en
matière d'égalité professionnelle.
62% de ses agents sont des femmes.
Elles sont majoritairement les
visages de la République.
Malgré les statuts, les grades,
les échelons qui définissent les
grilles de salaires, les
inégalités demeurent.
Nous n'avons pas encore atteint
l'égalité salariale ni la parité
dans l'accès aux postes à
responsabilités.
Les écarts de rémunération entre
les femmes et les hommes sont
encore de 12%.
Beaucoup de choses ont été faites
pendant le précédent quinquennat.
La loi de transformation de la
fonction publique du 6 août 2019,
portée par le ministre Olivier
Dussopt, sur laquelle je fus
rapporteur, prévoit que les
employeurs publics mettent en
place des plans d'action
pluriannuels relatifs à l'égalité
professionnelle entre les femmes
et les hommes.
Cela permet de s'attaquer à
plusieurs enjeux-clés, comme les
écarts de rémunération entre les
femmes et les hommes ou l'accès à
l'emploi de la fonction publique.
Cela contribue à mieux articuler
les vies professionnelles et
personnelles et à mieux prévenir
la discrimination ainsi que les
actes de harcèlement moral ou
sexuel.
Votre prédécesseure, Amélie de
Montchalin, a lancé un programme
pour encourager les femmes à
prendre des postes de
responsabilité.
L'égalité entre les femmes et les
hommes est une question
essentielle sur laquelle des
choses ont été faites et d'autres
restent à faire.
Vous êtes engagé sur le sujet, je
le sais.
Que comptez-vous faire pour rendre
exemplaire notre fonction
publique?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Stanislas
Guerini.
- Stanislas Guerini: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Monsieur le député, vous avez bien
fait de rappeler tout ce qui a été
fait en matière d'égalité entre
les femmes et les hommes dans la
fonction publique.
Je crois qu'on pourra tous en
convenir, le chemin reste long en
matière d'égalité professionnelle.
Avant de parler d'égalité
salariale, je voudrais vous parler
des conditions de travail.
Améliorer les conditions de
travail, c'est la condition
première pour que tous les
talents, toutes les compétences
puissent s'exprimer.
C'est la raison pour laquelle nous
avons placé notamment la santé des
femmes et la santé au travail,
avec la Première ministre, au
coeur de notre action pour les
mois et les années qui viennent.
Nous nous sommes attaqués à tous
les sujets, notamment aux sujets
qui étaient parfois tabous dans
notre société.
Je dis cela en pensant aux 150.000
femmes, tous les ans, qui
subissent des fausses couches.
La situation actuelle, c'est que
quand une femme subit une fausse
couche, légitimement, son médecin
lui prescrit un arrêt de travail,
en plus des traumatismes parfois
physiques, parfois psychologiques,
elle subit donc une pénalité
financière.
La situation actuelle, c'est qu'il
y a aujourd'hui un jour de carence
dans la fonction publique sur les
arrêts maladie liés aux fausses
couches.
Monsieur le député, grâce à
l'arbitrage immédiat d'Elisabeth
Borne, nous allons supprimer le
jour de carence lié aux fausses
couches dans la fonction publique.
Au-delà des conditions de travail,
nous irons plus loin en matière
d'égalité salariale.
Je l'annonce devant la
représentation nationale, nous
allons instaurer pour la fonction
publique un index d'égalité
salariale, qui existait jusqu'à
présent pour le privé.
Cet index, ce sera un outil
précieux pour pointer les
inégalités et pour faire bouger
tous les employeurs publics et de
tous les versants de la fonction
publique, parce qu'il y aura des
pénalités qui pourront
s'appliquer, et de tout cela, nous
pourrons parler pour, tous
ensemble, modifier la loi.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Serge
Muller.
- Serge Muller: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre de la Justice et garde
des Sceaux.
Dans mon département, la Dordogne,
où il y a quelques années on ne
fermait ni les portes de nos
maisons ni celles de nos voitures,
l'inquiétude s'installe et la
population se résigne.
En effet, la délinquance se
structure.
Elle s'organise.
Comme à Marseille, les dealers
affichent les tarifs sur les murs
des immeubles.
Nous ne sommes qu'à Bergerac.
Nous ne sommes qu'à Bergerac, dans
un département rural, réputé
calme.
Et pourtant, il y a des rues du
centre-ville qui deviennent zones
de non-droit.
Nombreuses sont les jeunes femmes
qui ne sortent plus seules.
Allez leur dire que l'insécurité
n'est qu'un sentiment quand les
viols et les agressions sexuelles
ont augmenté de 30% en un an.
Allez leur dire que l'insécurité
n'est qu'un sentiment quand les
coups et blessures volontaires ont
augmenté de près de 400% ces 20
dernières années.
Dans nos départements ruraux, où
les taux de pauvreté atteignent
les 20%, nous ne pouvons laisser
la délinquance s'organiser et se
structurer, au risque qu'elle
devienne inévitable, comme c'est
le cas aujourd'hui dans nos
métropoles.
Il nous faut des mesures fortes.
Alors, monsieur le ministre, je
vous le demande, pourquoi
êtes-vous opposé au rétablissement
des peines plancher, proposition
de votre propre majorité?
A cause de votre laxisme régalien
qui laisse se développer
l'insécurité, qui n'est pas qu'un
sentiment.
Monsieur le ministre, si un
sentiment peut blesser, je doute
qu'il puisse laisser des marques
indélébiles sur des visages.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Eric
Dupond-Moretti.
- Eric Dupond-Moretti: Les
oreilles m'en tombent lorsque je
vous entends, monsieur le député.
D'abord, je voudrais vous dire que
la proposition de loi de nos amis
de Horizons est une proposition de
loi que nous avons débattue ici
longuement.
L'Assemblée nationale a tranché.
Il est normal que les uns et les
autres puissent s'exprimer.
Ces murs ont des oreilles.
Ils ont aussi une mémoire.
Elle est retranscrite dans un
compte rendu.
Je voudrais vous dire que deux de
vos députés se sont
particulièrement illustrés.
Le premier souhaitait des peines
plancher absolument obligatoires,
et le juge ne pouvait pas s'en
sortir, si j'ose dire.
Il n'avait plus de liberté
juridictionnelle.
C'est totalement
inconstitutionnel.
Deuxièmement, l'une de vos députés
nous a dit que la justice était
laxiste.
C'est l'une de vos marottes.
Elle a dit qu'une cour d'assises
avait acquitté un certain nombre
d'accusés.
Quand vous serez au pouvoir, si
cela devait arriver, vous
condamnerez des hommes au bénéfice
du doute?
Voilà, monsieur le député, ne
cherchez pas à nous opposer à nos
amis d'Horizons.
Nous avons eu des débats sereins
et constructifs.
Nous avons argumenté.
Vous êtes, comme d'habitude, dans
l'excès.
Avant de m'asseoir, je voudrais
vous dire que des juridictions
font à cet instant l'objet de
coupures de courant.
Cette origine est une origine
malveillante.
La justice doit sans doute
s'arrêter pour certains d'entre
vous.
La désobéissance civile, c'est une
désobéissance à la loi.
- Serge Muller: Vous avez fait
vous aussi du bla-bla.
Vous n'avez pas répondu à ma
question.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Mathilde Desjonquères.
- Mathilde Desjonquères: Merci,
madame la présidente.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre de la Transition
écologique.
Le gouvernement a pris au Conseil
des ministres une ordonnance sur
la prise en charge des
conséquences des phénomènes
naturels de mouvements de terrain.
La moitié des maisons
individuelles en France sont
construites sur des sols argileux,
susceptibles de provoquer un
risque, à la suite d'épisodes de
sécheresse et de réhumidification
des sols.
Nous savons que la planète
connaîtra davantage d'épisodes de
chaleur extrême.
Les sinistres sont chiffrés à 45
milliards d'euros entre 2020
et 2022, 3 fois plus que les 13,8
milliards entre 1989 et 2019.
Si le phénomène de gonflement des
sols argileux est documenté en
France, il y a encore une
méconnaissance des sinistres et
des acteurs locaux sur l'impact de
la sécheresse et de ce phénomène
sur le bâti et les dispositions
constructives pour s'en prémunir.
Les sinistrés se sentent démunis
sur le coût des travaux.
Face à ce constat, ne serait-il
pas plus judicieux de trouver des
solutions durables pour prévenir
au mieux ce phénomène?
Il y a aujourd'hui une obligation
d'étude des sols, mais qu'en
est-il de l'obligation des
constructions pour mettre à l'abri
des fractures?
Ma deuxième question concerne les
victimes.
Que prévoit le gouvernement pour
les accompagner dans la
transformation de leur maison?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur
Christophe Béchu.
- Christophe Béchu: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Madame la députée,
j'associe Olivier Klein à la
réponse que je vais vous faire.
C'est un sujet que nous suivons
avec le ministère de la Ville et
du Logement.
Plus de la moitié des maisons
individuelles de ce pays sont
construites sur des terrains
argileux qui sont susceptibles
d'entraîner des risques de retrait
d'argile avec un aléa moyen ou
fort.
Les chiffres sont éloquents.
On était sur une moyenne de 0,5
milliards d'euros d'indemnisation
jusqu'à il y a quatre ans,
c'est 1 milliard d'euros par an,
en moyenne, et en 2022, ça
pourrait avoisiner les 3 milliards
d'euros.
Le gouvernement agit dans trois
directions.
Avec l'appui du Parlement dans le
cadre de la loi Elan,
principalement pour les ventes de
maisons, et pour les constructions
neuves, il y a une obligation
d'une étude géotechnique de
terrain qui est ensuite
communiquée au constructeur et qui
permet de diminuer le risque sur
la survenue de choses de ce type.
Pour l'essentiel, c'est lié à des
différentiels de terrain qui sont
provoqués par la sécheresse et à
des constructions qui ne sont pas
adaptées.
Reste le sujet de ceux qui sont
touchés.
Là, c'est l'ordonnance que nous
avons présentée le 8 février
dernier.
Ces ordonnances facilitent le fait
d'être indemnisé.
Ce n'est plus la sécheresse d'une
seule année qui compte.
Ensuite, on donne au propriétaire
un moyen de se prémunir contre
l'expertise assurancielle, pour
être défendu de manière à ce que
l'assureur ne rechigne pas à
payer, y compris pour les frais de
relogement.
Vous avez deux grands types de
dispositif: terrain neuf,
assurance.
Mais reste un nouveau volet.
Avec le réchauffement climatique,
est-ce qu'on ne doit pas penser à
d'autres modes plus pérennes, qui
ne reposent pas que sur l'origine
des catastrophes naturelles?
Cela fera partie de l'objet des
réflexions qui ont été confiées
aux services du ministère dans le
cadre du plan d'adaptation au
changement climatique.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Jean-Paul
Lecoq.
- Jean-Paul Lecoq: Merci.
Monsieur le ministre de
l'Economie, avec votre projet de
recul brutal des retraites,
l'envolée des prix alimentaires et
de l'énergie sont les premiers
sujets d'inquiétude des Français.
Avec 15% d'augmentation en moyenne
en un an, ces deux postes occupent
un tiers des dépenses des ménages
les plus modestes.
Cette situation est intenable.
Un chiffre dramatique le prouve.
Le recours à l'aide alimentaire a
triplé en 10 ans.
Dans votre logiciel ultralibéral
périmé, on n'exige jamais rien des
entreprises et des
multinationales.
Pour répondre la crise de
l'énergie, vous avez créé un
bouclier tarifaire qui s'est avéré
une ruine pour les finances
publiques, sans résoudre le
problème pour les Français.
Vous nous ressortez la même
routine pour la crise alimentaire
en demandant à la grande
distribution de faire un effort.
Un effort qui, au passage, va lui
permettre d'étouffer un peu plus
les petits commerçants, les petits
producteurs.
Aux riches, les demandes polies et
inefficaces.
Aux pauvres, l'aide alimentaire et
les réformes injustes.
Une seule solution permettrait de
se sortir de cette ornière:
l'augmentation des salaires, des
prestations et des pensions.
Depuis près de 15 ans, les
politiques de modération salariale
et vos réformes, qu'elles portent
sur l'assurance-chômage ou sur les
retraites, plombent le pouvoir
d'achat de l'immense majorité des
Français.
Beaucoup ne peuvent plus vivre
décemment des fruits de leur
travail.
Ils ne peuvent envisager de
s'offrir des produits locaux issus
de circuits courts ou simplement
de partir en vacances.
Il est donc temps d'assumer vos
choix politiques.
Pourquoi?
Pourquoi refusez-vous d'indexer
les salaires du public et du privé
sur l'inflation?
Pourquoi?
Et pourquoi refusez-vous
d'augmenter le SMIC, les
prestations et les pensions en
conséquence?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Bruno Le
Maire.
- Bruno Le Maire: Je peux
m'adresser à Jean-Paul Lecoq.
Il est juste en face de moi.
Il sait le respect que j'ai pour
lui.
Evitons les caricatures.
Je partage totalement ce que vous
dites sur...
- Qu'est-ce que c'est que cette
censure?
- Bruno Le Maire: Les deux postes
les plus lourds, c'est
effectivement l'énergie et
l'alimentation.
Sur l'énergie, aucun Etat européen
n'a fait autant que nous.
Nous avons mis en place un
bouclier sur l'électricité, sur le
gaz.
La facture aurait dû augmenter de
200 euros.
Dans certains pays européens,
c'est 300 euros.
Ce n'est pas le cas de nos
compatriotes.
Cela nous coûte 46 milliards
d'euros.
Dans une logique qui n'est pas
très libérale, nous sommes allés
prélever 26 milliards d'euros sur
les fournisseurs d'énergie.
Nous avons taxé lourdement les
fournisseurs d'énergie pour qu'ils
payent plus de la moitié de ce
bouclier énergétique.
Il y a ensuite l'alimentation.
Là aussi, nous ne sommes pas
restés les bras croisés en disant
que les prix alimentaires
augmenteraient et que nous ne
ferons rien.
Nous avons mis en place le
trimestre anti-inflation.
Ca va coûter plusieurs milliards
d'euros aux distributeurs.
Nous avons veillé à ce qu'on ne
touche pas à la loi EGalim, pour
que ce ne soient pas les
producteurs qui payent la facture
au bout du compte.
Je souhaite que les grands
industriels payent aussi la
facture.
Cela nous a amené à ce que l'on
renégocie les contrats fin juin
pour que les industriels prennent
aussi leur part de l'inflation.
Sur les salaires, le SMIC a
augmenté de plus de 8% depuis un
an.
Le salaire minimum est indexé sur
l'inflation.
Là où j'ai peut-être une vraie
différence avec vous, c'est que
j'estime qu'indexer tous les
salaires sur l'inflation, c'est
courir le risque d'entretenir
l'inflation là où notre objectif
premier, c'est de faire refluer
l'inflation.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Nicolas
Ray.
- Nicolas Ray: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre de la Santé.
21.000 lits fermés depuis 2017,
démissions de personnels, services
d'urgence saturés...
Ce sont les symptômes de la crise
profonde que traverse nos
hôpitaux, notamment dans nos
territoires ruraux.
Le plafonnement de la rémunération
des médecins intérimaires qui va
entrer en vigueur dans quelques
jours risque de déstabiliser un
peu plus nos hôpitaux en
sous-effectif.
Ma question portera plus
spécifiquement sur le manque
d'investissements dont souffrent
nos hôpitaux.
En effet, l'investissement
hospitalier a été divisé par deux
en 10 ans, que ce soit à Vienne ou
encore à Vichy, dans ma
circonscription, l'état des
bâtiments hospitaliers est
indigne.
A l'hôpital de Vichy, un
garde-corps est tombé du troisième
étage du bâtiment de
pédopsychiatrie.
Ce qui est choquant, c'est que de
nombreux hôpitaux connaissent un
manque de soutien d'ARS, tout
simplement parce que leur
situation financière est jugée
trop saine.
Lors du Ségur, l'hôpital de Vichy
n'a pas pu bénéficier pleinement
des aides à la reprise de dette
uniquement parce qu'il
n'atteignait pas le taux
d'endettement requis.
A ce jour, le projet de
construction du nouveau bâtiment
principal est toujours en attente
du soutien financier de l'ARS.
Visiblement, dans le système
actuel, on préfère sanctionner les
bons élèves.
Monsieur le ministre, plus que des
plans à répétition, nos hôpitaux
ont besoin d'une ressource
budgétaire pérenne et dédiée à
l'investissement, comme l'a
d'ailleurs recommandé la
commission d'enquête du Sénat.
Ma question sera simple:
comptez-vous enfin assurer un
financement stable, suffisant et
équitable entre les différents
hôpitaux de nos territoires?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à François Braun.
- François Braun: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Monsieur le député, je suis avec
une grande attention la situation
de nos hôpitaux.
J'en profite pour saluer
l'ensemble des soignants qui
continuent à tenir bon la ligne
dans des situations difficiles.
Je ne vais pas revenir sur tous
les éléments dont vous parlez.
Les fermetures de lits, c'est un
grand débat.
Je veux juste faire un petit point
sur l'intérim.
Vous semblez brocarder un peu
cette loi sur l'intérim.
Elle a été votée dans cet
hémicycle.
Nous ne faisons que l'appliquer.
Certes, un peu tardivement.
Concernant l'investissement dans
les hôpitaux, et je ne reviens pas
sur la reprise de dette qui a
permis à certains hôpitaux de
remonter la pente,
l'investissement est de 19
milliards d'euros.
Ce n'est pas tout.
Cela s'accompagne d'un changement
à l'intérieur même des hôpitaux
avec un changement de
fonctionnement, pour retrouver une
échelle beaucoup plus attractive
pour l'ensemble des soignants.
Cela ne vous aura pas échappé,
nous voulons revoir le financement
des hôpitaux, comme l'a annoncé le
président de la République.
En ce qui concerne l'hôpital de
Vichy, je vous confirme que nous
comptons l'accompagner de manière
très significative, toujours dans
le cadre de ce Ségur
d'investissement.
Le budget est en train d'être
structuré et séquencé avec les
élus autour de 130 à 140 millions
d'euros sur une période de 5 à 10
ans.
Cela fait suite à un projet
médical.
Bien entendu, l'Etat sera présent
aux côtés de l'établissement pour
conduire cette rénovation.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
- Nicolas Ray: Le président de la
République a fait de nombreuses
annonces lors de ses voeux.
Monsieur le ministre, nous
attendons des actes concrets et
des engagements précis.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La séance des
questions au gouvernement
est terminée.